hey everybody welcome or welcome back to
rollback what is rollback well rollback
is where
we serve up the very best of our
pre-video episodes to youtube for the
very first time and today we've got a
special one for you
ever since he snatched a video camera
from his father's closet at 15
stevo has lived for attention and the
jackass star learned early on that the
public adoration he craved escalated in
lockstep with his outrageous behavior
the further he pushed the envelope the
more america's favorite prankster felt
loved and alive but of course it was
never enough
and as insanely dangerous as his stunts
eventually became it was drugs and
alcohol that ultimately brought steve to
his knees
in this episode from may 15 of 2016
we go beyond quote unquote stevo the
alter ego to meet stephen glover the
human being behind the stuntman and
provocateur
and what makes it all the more unique
steve's father ted joined us as well
so this is a conversation about the
damage inflicted by addictions it's
about recovery forgiveness and spiritual
evolution
but most of all it's about the love
between a father
and a son
so this is me stevo
and ted glover
how's it going go man hi brother
my dad i'm ready
i'm so excited about this
man thanks for doing it yeah of course
man yeah i remember people asking me
about you and your podcast before
realizing that that i knew you man i
have so many questions for you i got a
lot for you steve let me just hear how
you sound yeah dude perfect that's so
cool you came here man i really oh man
it's uh it's more fun for me because
then i get to see like how they're sure
and everything like that right so i you
know i don't mind it i mean i have a
little studio but i live so far away
like getting people to come out to where
i am is tough sometimes i do it at the
house but
so does that mean we're underway we're
going all right here we are to broadcast
we got steve we got ted thank you for
doing this and ted by the way is
uh papa stevo that's right it's uh have
you ever done a podcast before never
done a podcast dad's probably never
listened to a podcast either
walter it's gonna be it's it's gonna be
good i got so many questions for you ted
for me yeah absolutely i mean come on
what's it like to be stevo's dad
i didn't know
that you would even be aware that i was
here
and i thought i'd i i advertised you i i
made a big deal it was your yeah it was
your idea but it was right and i think
that there's so much stuff that dad
would um
really um bring value to and and that
that i i
kind of curse myself for not having
exploited you
more
capitalized on my greater wisdom right
right dad's really uh because because
with the jackass history of bam
beating up his dad and sort of being
generally like terrible to his parents
you know like in my worst
uh at the the depths of my alcoholism
and drug addiction you know like there
was never a point when i ever
really [ __ ] on my family you know like
it's just not been
my shtick it's never been my deal
and um
even at my worst i've always you know i
i always made it home you know like for
christmas isn't that you know
for the most part except for having no
regard for my you know
my own well-being and then of course in
turn that's kind of [ __ ] on your
family well i think that
that you know behind all the insanity
you know liv's a pretty sweet kid you
know with a with a big heart i think
that's a big part of the jackass success
and i don't know i think i think people
i think people get that on some level
about you but i don't know if they
really get it in the way that like you
know we don't know each other that well
but i know you a little bit like
i know what you like when the camera's
off and sure you know you're a lot more
grounded you know shockingly more
grounded than i think people would
imagine i think that's fair to say and i
should also say uh say thank you for the
kind words it's uh it's appreciated
right and we've known each other for
going i mean i just turned eight years
sober right so
that's amazing i mean i guess i was
probably
we probably met i was about in about a
year yeah i think that's i think that's
about right so we've known each other
you know
somewhat peripherally for a good seven
years but yeah yeah yeah for sure i mean
it's been what an insane journey man
right you know i mean it's a freaking
miracle you know and when i'm driving
over here uh you know i listened to
uh the marin uh interview the other day
and and it was it was before you had
gotten back to me and i'm like
[ __ ] man what am i going to talk to this
guy about he just he just told the whole
thing with mark and then you're like i
want to have my dad on the podcast and i
was like that's genius
that's perfect like this has never
happened before so this is it's never
happened before and um
and and selfishly i you know because i
consider you to be
an authority on not just a vegan
lifestyle but but health and nutrition
in general
selfishly i kind of hope that that we
can get into a little bit of a
discussion that might influence you know
the old man to
to be a little bit more careful about
about
what he does and doesn't eat like you
know sort of and and i classified dad as
being um
it kind of like uh
he
he sort of
i don't know like defensive of certain
lifestyle habits
that until there's a burden of proof
and and it is it's conclusive and you
can not only like uh
prove why something's bad but boil it
down into
a manageable sound bite that can be
uttered in just one sentence and he's
going to hang on to bad habits until
right you know like and the first case
in point being uh diet diet soda well i
first of all i appreciate the the desire
to you know want to see the facts you
know that's that's a that's a admirable
quality so i don't uh disparage you for
that right
voice says it all
but the way is even quite right
on what he said i was trying to explain
it
with an advertising analogy you know i
started my career in the middle 1960s
and was marketing pretty well all the
way so
a fair amount of experience uh dealing
with advertising agencies and copy and
all the rest of it
and i said to steve if you've got a
product
that supposedly
polishes furniture better
reduces cavities in your teeth
example i used was head and shoulder
shampoo that controls dandruff
the first
the first thing the first thing you got
to start out with
is
what is the claim what are you saying
that this product stands for and is
capable of doing
the second level once you've established
the claim
is to define
the support for the claim
why
does the product do
how do you substitute the claim and uh
in the case of my early marketing days
when head and shoulders was literally
first introduced as a new product
a key ingredient the formula was a zinc
compound referred to as zpt
and that became the reason why
head and shoulders controls dandruff
because of this unique ingredient zbt
which
does all the terrific stuff so that's
the support family
then the third level
is the
documentation
that the support isn't all [ __ ]
right the clinical study that absolutely
proves it
back to steve's analogy
i gotta get to level two gotcha i gotta
understand why something is good but i
won't necessarily beat it to death to
get all the scientific studies
let's jump right in with with diet coke
okay so now dad tell me like why
do you feel so strongly about continuing
to uh drink diet coke
there's got to be some cognitive
dissonance because you know it's not a
health food well
all of my life i've been fighting
i've been fighting a battle of weight
gain i mean i'm not overweight but i
very easily could be
and so my first conscious thought
about healthy
eating or drinking or whatever
was focused on calories more than
anything else
so i concluded pretty quickly
that
a soda that has zero calories has got to
be more beneficial
in terms of weight control right than a
soda that's got
several hundred calories so that kind of
launched me on the uh
on the
diet soda kick and working in the
industry didn't hurt dad used to be a
pepsi cola right
so diet pepsi or diet diet pepsi
no it took 30 years to get out of that
when steve was little he wasn't allowed
to have coke
and if we were in a restaurant that was
a coke exclusive he drinks seven i hear
yeah but but that that's you realize
that's a myopic perspective because
you're overlooking all the the chemicals
and all the additives and all the other
things no no it's not my opinion all
right
let me define it this is a first step in
an evolutionary journey and not to be
disparaged
all right okay
[Music]
all right everybody hold on a second dad
what the hell are you talking about like
um what he said what do you say what he
said
when he said i know what's bad i'm
saying hey
i know
it's going to contribute less to obesity
and as i
progress this evolution then i'm
realizing that it's not great and so i'm
drinking more water and less soda but i
have not eliminated it completely but
but can we um let me let me can you help
me to get him to this
second level or whatever he's talking
about to understand like why it's
terrible let me about diet soda or just
let's or about the vegan lifestyle let's
go
let's let's try to knock out diet soda
rolls all right so well first as far as
diet soda is concerned your your
equation presumes that if you're not
drinking diet soda that you're going to
be drinking regular soda so that's error
number one right like neither of those
are good so
maybe maybe try to work on overcoming
that presumption i agree with that but
when you start on your journey less bad
is moving in the direction of good
uh-huh right right but when you're
okay i don't even know where to begin
with this
i know he's a logic machine and he uses
his logic very irrational i could talk
about i could talk about the vegan stuff
and the animal products in your diet if
you want to talk about that
well i i here i got kind of a separate
issue if
the entire vegan proposition
is based on cruelty to animals
steve has
made sure that i viewed the appropriate
video but dad's amazing
like for for those who aren't familiar
with the documentary called earthlings
it's probably the most
upsetting expose of of uh
animal cruelty and it's a documentary
that breaks down chapter by chapter the
ways in which humans exploit animals you
know first being not necessarily in this
order but uh but for food
for for clothing for entertainment for
animal testing and i feel like i'm
leaving out one but uh it's oh yeah and
for for uh pets
um
it's just the most like heart-wrenching
super upset upsetting thing and and and
uh my stepmom at the time when we uh
when i brought this documentary home
it was important to to show this to dad
and and my stepmom
the opening credits hadn't even
rolled and my stepmom went running out
of the room like like i can't stand i
can't see this like like almost like i'm
crying or crying
and dad like sat there and and watched
it through now while this documentary
was was you know playing i remember
thinking to myself i'm already vegan
like i'm already vegan like why am i
doing this to myself to watch this like
it just made me feel super vegan and um
and dad
you know like uh just sort of bonding
with me like they actually managed to
not fall asleep which was which was
pretty impressive
and um and made it all the way through
from beginning to end watch the whole
thing now the next day we went out to
lunch and both dad and stepmom
uh order
meat
they're like maybe whatever it was i
think it was like a a
caesar with chicken all over it or
something and um i remember just
thinking wow like
my my take on it at the time was well
you know um i i
genuinely and and not not to be mean or
anything i just i just can't respect the
uninformed decision to run out of the
room like i can't bear to see this and
then not change the way you live
it's basically acknowledging that
there's something really wrong there and
just just running out and and i don't
want to watch it and then and then not
changing the way that i have trouble
respecting that but i had to say even at
the time you know the fact that dad like
just parked down on the sofa watch this
whole documentary from beginning to end
became fully informed like it with all
of the the you know really really
difficult to watch uh you know video
component
and and just completely informed and
then just sat down and ordered himself
some chicken the next day like i don't
like it but
on on a level i had to disrespect that
like it was important it's sort of like
how upton sinclair you know would say if
you you can eat meat if you want but
first like tour the slaughterhouse so
you know what you're getting into right
so you're not going at it with writers
and and it's more and more difficult
we're more and more divorced as
consumers from the process by which our
food is made as a result of ag gag laws
and all sorts of you know regulatory
actions that prevent the consumer from
having that transparent uh relationship
with food manufacturers right
jumping completely to a tangent but
somewhat relevant
america
is one of only four or five countries
with a death penalty
others including saudi arabia and china
and it's been opined
that the fastest way to get rid of the
death penalty would be to put the
executions in television and force the
masses to watch them
i don't think that that would be the
case i don't know i don't know but but
but it's kind of to your point if you
look at all the bad stuff that's going
on you are more likely to be repelled by
it than if you stick your head in the
sand and pretend it doesn't exist well
it's a common saying that if
slaughterhouses had uh windows you know
or glass walls that you could see
through and everybody was just seeing
what was going on and then a lot more
people would be yeah but i'm going to
use my logic now i guess in an
inappropriate way logic is usually good
but
this one a little bit inappropriate
um
i got a lot of respect for steve's care
about animals and
if i were looking at it only on a health
benefit basis and not on a cruelty to
animals basis
i could pretty quickly conclude that
three-quarters vegan is better than no
vegan and have a steak now and again and
you're still leading a healthier life
and it is not like alcohol or drugs
which become addictive and one slip and
you're down the slippery slope again
yeah so that
i i disagree there because when like
when once you're when when you've
established like a principle of it's
wrong
to
tell her we're
harming animals like once every few
months or no no wait wait i'm breaking
the
argument into two component parts okay
i'm dealing first with the health issue
as it relates to the consumer
the animal issue is a separate issue
right okay
as the consumer uh three-quarters vegan
has got to be healthier than zero vegan
now going to your point about cruelty to
animals and this is where i get a little
bit unglued
steve doesn't wear leather
and i respect that
on the other hand the industry
has become so incredibly
good
at designing fake leather that's
indistinguishable from the real product
if steve goes to a function
wearing a belt or shoes that is
indistinguishable from real leather
everybody thinks that
he's okay yeah i thought about that too
when i go out in public like i try to
wear stuff that doesn't look like
leather at all so somebody so people
won't get confused in that way i mean
you know that's sort of uh
you know we're getting into like the
minute i mean i think that but backing
up i want to get back to something you
said earlier which was your presumption
of approaching this issue from a
perspective of of
ethics and and uh the treatment the
mistreatment of animals but there's also
like you began to allude to the health
considerations and also profoundly the
environmental implications so there's a
right i'm sure you saw a couch
i watched it with dad okay got dad to
watch cowspiracy and and he showed up to
lunch the next day
yeah so the way i look at it is like
this
it checks every it checks every box
because uh when you break down the
you know the system of factory farming
and industrialized animal agriculture
and the massive deleterious impact of
that industry on planetary health
everything from species extinction to
ocean dead zones to water use to land
use to rainforest you know rainforest
deforestation everything about that is
so profoundly more harmful than all of
transportation combined etc then you
look at health and you realize we're in
the midst of this unspeakable health
care crisis right now one out of every
three americans dies of heart disease by
2030 50 of americans are going to be
diabetic or pre-diabetic 70 of americans
are obese or overweight and i would
contend that we actually are addicted on
some level not maybe the way that you
become addicted to cocaine but there is
an addictive element to some of the
foods that we eat particularly some of
the more highly processed foods so
by removing animal products from your
diet you're taking out an insurance
policy on your health to not become one
of those chronic lifestyle illness
statistics you're doing uh right by the
environment and you're sparing the life
of animals that are being mistreated so
when i look at it from like a ten
thousand foot down uh perspective i see
all these reasons why yeah one stop shop
yeah so check it out that's how i i tend
to think about it but i also
um
you know i'm somebody who i don't go
around preaching and telling people what
they should or they shouldn't do like
i've lived my life i'm happy to talk
about it people want to hear about it if
they're interested i'll answer questions
but i don't sit in judgment of anyone
else's lifestyle but i do think that
we're at like you know a chronic point
in our in our planet where we have to
you know really figure some stuff out
because we're headed in a not so good
direction well let me i'm interrupting
on purpose and i apologize for that but
uh i think i don't think it's fair to
say that we don't sit in judgment of uh
people's lifestyles because i think that
we that we do i think what we refrain
from doing is attacking them and
preaching to them mm-hmm it's about but
we can't be removed from judgment i
don't think and and really having this
conversation fair enough let me try to
put a pragmatic
twist in this uh
the principal home is in florida and we
got the great big plastic recycling bins
and i recycle like a trooper i believe
in it i make sure that everything goes
out a soda can or a plastic bottle
will never go into the trash
we have an apartment in london
that we spend you could go to in the
summer and it's a small apartment
you know it's a london uh
england england london yeah yeah
and uh in ontario
and the uh
you know
there's a space constraint
and to have a separate
container for recycling
wouldn't fit into the kitchen
and so it is a significantly greater
pain in the ass
to think about recycling soda cans in
our place in london than it is in
florida
so i do the cost-benefit analysis
i'd like to help save the world
within reasonable uh costs of effort and
time i'll be absolutely committed as i
am in florida
but if the difficulty of doing that you
know reaches a certain level the cost
benefit clicks in i think hey if i throw
yeah 100 soda cans out in the course of
the summer i don't think the world is
going to be down hundreds of cans well
the greater point the greater point that
you're making is that if you really want
to if you really want to make change on
a mainstream mass level the healthy
choice or the choice that's better for
you know
for society and the planet at large has
to be the convenient choice
i think that's right yeah right and i
think there's a real point there's
another point that movie that that's
that's the one we saw at christmas time
right with the map and how how the all
the cows have the conspiracy one right
yeah and that dad has a [ __ ] on every
single one of these doctors no i'm not
shooting no no i know i remember you
said you came to lunch the next day you
ordered yourself somebody it wasn't you
know you said he said that that um the
main the main thing that the cowspiracy
thing was called was consumption of
water right if i remember correctly and
they were talking about
um you know like imagine uh
uh you know
leaving the hose running and the
neighbor left the hose running and and
it flooded everywhere you know you'd say
something and you tell them to stop
dad's point was
he said he said i don't i don't buy it
because um it's impossible to um to use
this water for for for this uh you know
uh agriculture
without
effectively recycling it one way or the
other so you don't lose the water is
what dad was saying
okay if we could respond to that that
would be helpful i'm not sure i'm not
sure i totally understand you're saying
that that can that that that consumer
that that water has to get used one way
or another and it's not fine
i'm not sure i said that i mean i think
the bigger issue is that is that
using animals as a
repository for food is inherently
wasteful
and unsustainable because you have to
cycle all these crops through an animal
and you end up with less food than if
you just fed the human beings the crops
themselves and so you have to pour all
these resources into growing an animal
to the size that it can be slaughtered
for for food
and because of that
uh it's just it's inefficient and as a
business person you know economies of
scale and efficiencies i would think are
something that is always on your mind
well that's the same argument that
undermines the case for electric or
hybrid cars
because everybody says hey they don't
use any gasoline
and they use little or no gasoline
depending on which model you buy but
nobody calculates the
renewable or non-renewable renewable
energy which is required to make the
batteries and you know run the turbines
that provide the electricity that kind
of all gets lost in the shuffle all
right so ted how we how we can solve all
these problems well i've got a solution
for the water
you do all right
and i want to use an analogy with the
oil industry
because if you go back six or seven
years everyone was talking about peak
oil the world was running out
saudi arabia was hitting its peak and
about to decline
the i forget the name of the field but
in the gulf of mexico off the coast of
mexico was declining by 15 or 20 percent
every year
this was a dire thing
and guess what happened
american ingenuity came up with the
technology of hydraulic fracturing and
suddenly the world is awash with a
surplus
and my view is not saying this would
solve it but an equally constructive
avenue
maybe to approach in tandem
for the water problem
is to concentrate on
much larger scale desalination
technology
if you could take salt water
and the technology exists but not on a
scale or cost structure that would make
it viable to
water the crops across america but why
couldn't
water be taken from the ocean
desalinated
used to
irrigate crops
and you get the dual benefit of not only
solving the water shortage but at least
partially addressing the
you know the global warming the ice cap
melting and then
the rising ocean is going to wipe out
florida in a hundred years i talked
about this with joe rogan on his podcast
and my theory on this is that it seems
like uh it seems like desalinating the
ocean would be like elementary school
chemistry like why can't we just get
this the salt out of the ocean it seems
like it would be simple but it's not
very difficult it takes a lot of energy
to do it it's so complicated i think
that god rigged it because if it was
easy those oceans would be dry by now
because human beings are
idiotic though yeah look look we're i'm
not saying i'm not saying it's easy i'm
not saying it's viable
i'm just saying that if you are trying
to take forget just the american public
the world public
and get them off eating meat
i submit that that is an even bigger
challenge
than
developing desalination plants on a vast
commercially viable scale he might have
a point and if you were to pursue both
avenues simultaneously you would
probably have a greater chance of
success in pursuing one only we still
don't have enough land to raise the
number of animals to anticipate the
needs of a planet that's going to swell
to 11 billion people by 2100
yeah i think that's right
now the other thing
if you look at two
separate
industries with related issues
when
i was in my twenties
it was perfectly common to go out into
friday night get totally wasted and
drive home at two o'clock in the morning
the time when steve was
little we lived in connecticut about an
hour's drive from manhattan and steve's
mom and i would literally go down to
central manhattan after work leaving the
kids with a babysitter
drink ourselves shit-faced until one
o'clock in the morning and then drive
home along the hutchison river merritt
parkway if you know it there's no lights
and it's a winding road uh
i sometimes marvel that i'm still alive
today those are the good old days no no
no no no wait wait wait wait wait wait
they're not the good old days but here's
the difference uh over time there was a
societal change and drinking and driving
not only became
penalized criminally
it became socially unacceptable
uh and once it becomes socially
unacceptable and people are embarrassed
to do it that changes habits uh i spent
four years uh in the cigarette industry
as head of the uh latin america
operations
for rj reynolds tobacco right that's
amazing and and uh i remember at the
time
the industry was far more concerned
about losing
social acceptability than losing
lawsuits
yeah because once that tide shifts
you're done yeah and i think that the if
you if you really want to change
uh
behavior
there's got to be a hook that
influences people to uh
look down on the meat eater the way
currently people look down on the smoker
i mean if you're in a social function or
a business function and somebody's got
to go out for a cigarette break yeah at
best they're
lower level socio-demographics and
probably they're an [ __ ] uh
if you could convey that kind of
thinking uh well i think we're headed in
that direction as a result of some
pretty interesting technological
advances and what's going on with the
kind of meat alternative industry with
beyond meat and hampton creek these
these are really pioneering interesting
companies that are coming up with
everything from burgers to mayonnaise to
cookie dough and beyond and this is only
going to enhance there's companies like
memphis meats that are they're growing
in petri dishes like steaks and all
kinds of cream the technology that's
going into this is amazing and i think
we're not there yet certainly but 5 10
15 maybe 20 years from now
when we're able to produce foods that
are indistinguishable in taste and amino
acid profile and nutrients and all of
that from animal products then i think
we will get to a tipping point where
mainstream culture will shift their
perspective because why
participate in the killing of a innocent
animal when you can get this alternative
that actually
is more nutritious tastes just as good
etc i think there may be a shortcut to
that and this is a conversation we had
at dinner the other night
i don't like
vegan
uh call it rip off burgers or mock meat
mocking anything i mean anybody who is
has not yet converted and enjoys a good
steak or a good hamburger a good piece
of chicken is not gonna particularly
enjoy it's getting better though it's
getting better but it's gone from very
bad to somewhat bad
here is the suggestion we were
i forget the name of that restaurant the
other night and veggie girl and there
was one dish in the menu
which i would classify as real food
the bombay bowl right and i loved it
and i'm not gonna go back to the same
restaurant if they've only one dish in
the menu that i like but i don't
understand why these restaurant
proprietors don't recognize
that there's a huge value in creating
meals that aren't pretending to be
something right i think there was an
idea that that veggie grill had to have
those sort of chicken sandwiches and
burgers and the like to kind of get a
mainstream audience in but they're
they're actually pivoting right now and
and doing exactly what you you're saying
they're going to be putting more you
know sort of whole food you know real
food uh items on the menu and they've
been incredibly successful too i mean
this chain it's a southern california
operation that has just exploded and
they've got new
new locations opening up that was just
up in portland oregon they have a veggie
grill oh they do up there uh-huh you
know what's opening in portland pretty
soon what's that this uh
this uh all vegan grocery store called
vegan like it's a full grocery store but
everything in there is vegan it's this
guy who used to be a mercedes-benz
executive uh and started this chain in
berlin there's a couple in germany and
he's they're introducing their first one
in the u.s you know exactly but
can you can you buy tide detergent and
heineken beer there that's a good
question i'll tell you i got a real
[ __ ] against whole foods i hate that
place
because
because whole you can afford it
but
the cost is not the issue
you walk in and in the front end they
got fresh vegetables that are pretty
good
they got a lot of meat down the back
but the steaks are too big i'm eating
less meat which i guess is a step in the
right direction
instead of having a 20 ounce steak i'm
happy with the 12-oz steak um
but in the middle they got all these
fufu products
and if you want to do a total shop there
you can't so you got to go to whole
foods for this but you still got to go
to publix or ralph's or wherever you
live
in order in order to fill out your your
shopping list like what yeah what are
you trying to get i want to get beer i
want to get detergent beer i want to get
toothpaste i'm sure they do but they
they don't have the same brands they try
to they try to get these niche craft
brands
if if you got
all right hold on let's like
and paper towels can you get paper
towels and whole foods i want to talk
about like how
your your dad clearly has a methodical
like logically based plotting mind like
i don't like the word plotting where are
you i don't like the word plotting
nothing
real quick that i remember this was i've
been on kind of a crusade to try it
because i mean i love my dad so much and
you know dad just turned 73 um in the
family history there's uh you know
there's there's dementia there's cancer
there's this and that and and uh the
idea of of uh
of losing my dad or having forbidden any
downgrade of you know dad like you know
downgraded in any way is terrifying to
me and and uh you know i i clutch to him
like last night we went to a doctor game
and uh i didn't say this i don't know
why i'm staying now but um when they
they run everybody through a metal
detector and um and and as uh you know
like
you know dad
said to the very almost like uh
sheepishly you know like for my dad the
way i understand the way i know him he
said i have a pacemaker and i can't go
through the metal detector and that dad
when you said that that hit me so hard i
didn't mean to do that but i'll tell you
it just hit me really really hard like
like it was like like uh
i was confronted with my dad's mortality
which uh which i'm just not open to
being confronted with you know and so
for all these years
i've been uh you know since i started
taking care of myself i've been really
campaigning dad to take care of himself
you know because uh because i just i
want to keep him around and i want him
in the best shape i can have him um so
part of the campaign was i came home and
i come home with documentaries all the
time and dad you know as sort of a
bonding thing you know father and son
he'll he'll watch just about whatever i
bring home with him you know to to spend
time with me and it's always geared
towards trying to get dad to live more
healthy and one of the trips home was
that we sat down and watched the
documentary food matters
dad always comes away with the take on
it some kind of a a dad's spin that just
like just undermines everything he's
just seen just like
did we just watch the same movie
right
but uh but the thing about food matters
and and this is you know for people who
don't know it's a documentary that
basically like extols the virtue of a
raw food diet and it says that you know
if you go to whole foods or something
you know and to buy your uh your
uh your raw produce
that that that raw produce has lived on
uh on a truck
which brought it from wherever it was
farm
by the time it gets to the grocery store
it's basically lost all of its new
nutritional value and it's no longer
everything that's why it's so important
that
you've got to go to uh get get it from
your local you know local or grant
organic you know it's got to be locally
sourced you know farmer's market like
and so dad
and i kind of understand it and not even
a little bit with them on that dad's
like okay so this documentary that my
takeaway is that no matter what you do
it's just not good enough you know even
if i go to whole foods and buy all the
the organic
veggies and this and that they've lost
all their nutrients so no matter what
you do you're screwed and that's right
so just so just [ __ ] it and like
i mean like and i think that's a problem
yeah but let me me see
i i don't think vegetables hurt you i i
suppose if they got too much pesticides
in them but to me
vegetables in the scenario you describe
go from a plus to a zero
but what is scarier is that
i grew up
being told that white meat and fish
were healthy alternatives to red meat
and when you see all these uh
documentaries
about the the poultry i mean that
doesn't look any safer than red meat and
then you read about the uh mercury in
the water and you eat fish and you get
mercury and there's one astonishing
thing in the local paper in west palm
beach
a lot of sport fishermen up there
and they somehow did a study
with families that uh fished
sufficiently regularly
that their meal was based on
fresh-caught fish
i think three times a week or more four
times a week or more very very high
incidence of catching their own fish in
the waters
off the uh east coast of florida
and then
they did some kind of a study and i for
i don't remember the specifics but the
conclusion
was that these people had a particularly
high incidence of something that was bad
like even the fish that you caught off
the local pier
you know had a bunch of crap in it so
steve's right i mean you do get to a
point where
if everything is bad and then you got
the all the studies about how coffee
used to be dreadfully bad and now coffee
is okay
wine was bad but if you drink a couple
of bottle glasses of wine every day you
got it there was almost a freudian slip
in there
the word bottle almost came well
once upon a time
once upon a time there was and as steve
will acknowledge i
don't think i was ever an alcoholic i
certainly was an alcohol abuser i could
drink a bottle of scotch in a night if
it was a long enough night
steve's stepmom my wife got me off of
that
uh i'll have a couple of scotches a
month i'll have a single beer with most
meals
but it doesn't go beyond that yeah dad's
uh you know the in the book he's the the
problem drinker who's able to to
moderate you know when when given a
sufficient reason well that's what your
book said not my book that's what the
big book said
what if your book says no i i say
when
when steve when steve first went into
his recovery process i read the aaa book
i went to allen on i made a point of
trying to understand more clearly what
it was all about it's so funny that that
dad said says so you know because i told
him right when i went in dad you have to
you know go to allen on and go because
otherwise you have to understand what
i'm going through and you got to kind of
figure out how to not screw it up you
know and so you i need to go to allen on
now it's about six months in dad says so
i've been going to eleanor and i just
don't quite understand it because it
seems like the people in these al-anon
meetings are there discussing their own
problems
and i don't have any problems
i don't know
i don't have anything so well he says
i'm just here to
to be supportive you know to to
understand and support you and what
you're doing he went though he went yeah
and and i remember thinking it was
hilarious and i said dad next time just
hand me a joint and a beer and call it a
day right no that's not fair
right now let me ask you this let me
when when when steve started getting
super crazy i mean what was that like
for you awful i mean it had to be
torture
usually
almost invariably i didn't see any
footage until obviously long after it
was taken so the immediate life for
death threat
uh wasn't an issue because i talked to
him in the phone
the week or the day before
what i was looking at
on the footage had obviously been filmed
much longer ago than that
and
both of my kids especially my daughter
legitimately criticized me for what they
call rose-colored glasses i mean
i'll usually find a positive spin to put
on just about anything
and uh
i did delude myself that uh yeah there
was a problem but it was not as big a
problem as you know everybody said it
was it you know one way or another
things would sort themselves out and
obviously
they did but not in the way i expected
and not in any uh
sort of evolutionary change it was a
crisis that
you know right and and i had like that i
i
essentially had that you know a black
male operation going where you know i
was self-sufficient you know my own
you know
financial right uh so he couldn't tell
you what to do yeah i wasn't i wasn't
dependent on anybody financially or
otherwise and so it was just sort of
like a hey you know like i'm going to
need you to shut up and if you don't
like that then you're just sort of i'm
going to you know you're not going to be
able to have a relationship with me so
it was very much like on my terms
and uh and and and i was you know it's
like typical for an alcoholic addict
like you know if anybody brought up my
lifestyle my health like my my you know
my heaven forbid my addiction
um i just barked again i turned really
really harsh really cold really fast and
uh and just shut down and uh that was
the end of that conversation and so
nobody was invited to bring it up and
and if anybody did bring it up they they
i made them regret it in short order and
uh if they persisted with it then they
jeopardized their ability to have a
relationship with me at all and so so
with ted it's a little bit of denial or
just sort of believing that you know
it'll somehow it's going to work out and
just kind of and also being trained very
well to to know not to bring it up you
know to kind of dance around it but
believe it or not there was a silver
lining and all that
because when steve had his ultimate
collapse and was talking about riding
his motorcycle through the glass window
to land in the building across the
street
uh i got calls from
knoxville right when knoxville was
arranging the intervention the idea was
to have dad be be physically present
there and so let's just let's paint that
picture quickly because it's pretty
interesting i mean i know you've heard
the story before but i mean you were
you know you were headed towards the end
there and going
i was in dire straits i mean i i my
disease of addiction had progressed and
um you know for many years and i mean my
first time in rehab was 1995
and i kind of blazed out of there and
and uh you know i had serious issues and
by the end of it
um by the end of it i was just so
in such a bad way that i had effectively
burned all the bridges in my career um
you know like any good kind of a
business opportunity i i made go away
um i uh
just was i became like like quite truly
uh
just a nasty person i think that the way
that we treat others
is is a pretty pure reflection of how we
feel about ourselves and my my
self-image my self-esteem
i hadn't had just been driven so low
that i didn't have very many nice things
to say or do and towards others and and
i was i was pretty nasty i would try to
harm people's reputations uh you know
make them feel bad i am
not all the time but but that was a big
chunk of what i was up to and and for
the most part just becoming
uh you know inebriated and intoxicated
uh you know to to to really kind of
dangerous levels and and and i would
sleep but once every
you know three days right so it's like
coke pcp ketamine alcohol right
everything except for crack and heroin
like i was part of my deal i never why
not
i had boundaries for that and the reason
why is because i had been in uh when i
was in in rehab in 1995 when i was 20
years old um
i i mean i wasn't even of legal drinking
age at that point so when i got to the
rehab
you know i was just like i was just kind
of getting my feet wet a little bit i
mean i wasn't i was a proper alcoholic
but once i was in the mix of of the
rehab center that i was in
it was like okay well these people
that have real problems made me feel a
little bit better about myself by
comparison i didn't have that much of an
issue and um
like the the the way that it was set up
you know that everybody was you know
we'd be in our circles sort of talking
about our feelings this and that and um
every day one person would for the most
part one person would leave and another
person would show up this was the
turnover and so whenever a new person
showed up what you did
you know that person would walk up to
the to the to the circle and introduce
yourself to the group and say what your
drug of choice was and i learned really
quickly that uh
how people reacted to the new guys
showing up if they were to say
um my my drug of choice is powder
cocaine like snorting cocaine they would
like to be smirking they'd be laughing
like what a [ __ ] you know they'd be
basically saying under their breath but
if their person was to say my drug of
choice is crack cocaine it would just be
like all of a sudden you know avert eye
contact i don't want to know this guy
he's not my roommate you know this is
sort of the feeling i got from it it was
like wow like i don't know what the
difference is between powder cocaine
and and crack cocaine but whatever that
difference is it is very significant
because people would talk about
about having careers with drugs and
alcohol that went forever and ever even
heroin you know whatever like just they
were maintained for years and years and
years and then like from the moment they
took their first hit of crack cocaine
like in in just such a short time they
lost everything right and i learned that
really really effectively when i was in
that rehab like whatever you do just do
not smoke crack right that's pcp no
problem yeah
right i mean i remember seeing and then
the um the nitrous and heroin too yeah
nitrous was terrible i mean what was it
there was some show
mtv where you're at the end and you're
like lying around and there's just like
nitrous cartridges like just surrounding
you like right and and i never even
really i was kind of like ashamed of it
at the time like i never really
documented the you know like if i if i
hadn't been i was always trying to sort
of like manage it and they're kind of
like
not like you know like there's just no
video footage that that lives that could
do justice to
to the extent of the the
nitrous consumption i was i was i was up
to that mtv special did a pretty good
job though yeah you knew it was dark
that was dark yeah yeah it was dark and
i don't even know i frankly i wouldn't
actually wound up i wouldn't watch it
for the longest time this was for those
who don't know they made a documentary
um i handed over like you know like a
box of video when i was fairly new in
rehab and
and just just handed over with my
blessing to make a documentary about you
know about my stuff
um
which
which is sort of a you know
i don't know
thank god i didn't go on that celebrity
rehab because they were recording me
like so
persistently and uh they were they were
casting the second season of dr drew's
celebrity rehab when i was
you know like a
couple months like two or three months
in and um they would and i couldn't say
no i don't want to do it and then they
kept like upping the money upping the
money and to the point where i was like
considering it it would have been the
worst thing ever for me to to do that
and i look at what i did do with this it
was called stevo demise and ryze and it
was a basically basically a documentary
about my downward spiral and my
subsequent um early recovery
and
you know it came and went and i think
for a lot of people who put their
recovery out there in the way of some
kind of media you know if it's a
documentary if it's a tv show or this
and that i think that people who sort of
tout their recovery
um
don't
don't typically do as well in recovery
you know if you're sort of busy drawing
attention to it and touting it and sort
of congratulating yourself because
that's that can become a problem that
becomes really tricky because your whole
motivation uh becomes sketchy and i
remember being kind of aware and
thinking of it as sort of that kind of a
curse and i think thinking really second
guessing myself questioning like why am
i why am i doing this and like and is am
i doing am i dooming myself to fail a
lot of it's about intention though you
know it's like is this being driven by
ego and finances or or is it a vehicle
to you know be of service to other
people
i you know i i
i think it was a little bit of
everything on the honest truth i think
was a little bit of everything it wasn't
it wasn't purely uh positive motivation
it wasn't um and it wasn't entirely
negative at all but um looking at it and
i remember um
you know kind of really agonizing over
like am i putting myself am i putting my
recovery in jeopardy by putting this
documentary out there and one guy who
really gave me um
maybe maybe i i said this recently but
uh but it's james hetfield from
metallica because that documentary that
metallica did which was called some kind
of monster which which chronicled them
uh replacing a band member
um recording therapy right together and
all the therapy and it basically at the
end of the day what it really was was a
documentary about the lead singer of
metallica james hetfield and his early
recovery because he just is fresh out of
rehab and he's got a limit on how much
time you can spend rehearsing with the
band and he's just like she's so raw and
he's so
um and it was it was basically a
documentary about his recovery and um i
look at that and and i looked at it at
the time when i was doing my documentary
and for metallica you know that came
that went and uh it was sort of back to
the business of being metallica and um
and and james hadfield didn't go on to
write on write songs about making amends
or they're working the 12 steps of
recovery it was just sort of like he put
that out there and it didn't kind of
define him it just sort of like put it
out there and he moved on and and that
guy really i really held on tightly to
the idea of that and sort of
letting that kind of be my model for how
to to to view that documentary and how
to approach it because i remember
meeting james hetfield at a uh at a
metallica concert right when i got my
nine-month sobriety chip and of course
like the the chips that we get in in
sobriety
up until a year
they're they're they're made out of
plastic and then when you get when you
get your first year it's a it's a coin
and so i met james hedfield backstage at
the metallica concert and i asked him i
said hey man how long have you been
sober and he said seven years it was at
that time and i mean it was just it was
evident it was written all over his face
you could just see like the health the
the the happiness like it was just like
to me he was just the most like shining
example of like meaningful recovery he
said seven years and i said oh man cool
and i pulled out my my nine month chip
and i said i just got my nine months
chip and i held it up to him and i said
no more plastic for me man straight
heavy metal from here on out you know
meaning that it was my intention to
really like protect my sobriety and and
uh
and stay in sort of the business of
getting here coins and not going back to
picking up plastic chips and uh you know
i bought that that guy was just such a
such a uh you know i just have so much
respect for him and uh and just how like
he's done it you know and um i just like
i mean i i don't know him personally and
i haven't heard anything about but just
for the way that he that uh what i do
know about how he approached it you know
i just think he's really stayed with it
and and stayed true to it and he remains
someone who uh
who i respect and look up to you know
yeah it's that's an amazing story you
know it's an amazing story and but but
back to
uh you know final days for you right you
know when this is when all this insanity
is going on and you're firing off emails
every 20 minutes to everybody in
hollywood telling you like what you're
gonna do and you're going to ride your
motorcycle through your apartment and
i'll ride it
there's the living room had a sliding
glass door i was going to open the
sliding glass drawer and put a ramp in
the living room i wanted to ride a
motorcycle i'd jump it off the ramp and
uh out the sliding glass door which
would which would launch me out and i
wanted to land on the roof of the
building next door which was very doable
knoxville looked at it and they said
knoxville looked at it and said over
there there's not much of a gap right
there like it actually made fun of me
for that being like right it's like
super easy
[Laughter]
but but what but then in my bedroom
there was a window and uh and out out
that windows you know some 25 feet down
to the to the sidewalk below
and um
and and i was emailing everybody in
hollywood like with the jackass guys
copied you know i want you guys to bring
me uh something to land on i'm gonna
jump out the window i've got been
evicted and i've got to be out of here
but by tomorrow so let's start filming a
third jackass movie and
bring me something to land on preferably
a hot tub for me that i wanted to like
jump into a hot tub because it wasn't a
very high jump you know a cannonball
into a hot tub would have been doable
but but if you can't bring a hot tub
like made at least some cardboard boxes
but no matter what come bring cameras
and if you don't bring anything if you
don't come if you don't uh you know like
you know uh fulfill my my request
uh you know if you if you don't like you
know do what i say then i promise you
i'm gonna jump anyway
and i'm gonna find out how many bones
get broken when i splat on the concrete
you know on the sidewalk because i'm
ready to die and i'm gonna jump and so
that qualified me for uh right you're
architecting your own uh interventions i
scheduled my own intervention yeah and
created the proof to uh have it locked
up i provided the documentation to
qualify me for california's 5150 law
which states that if somebody is harmful
to themselves or others that they can be
locked up in a psychiatric ward against
their will right now so you set up a
call time and you think these guys are
going to all come over and film you and
that's where they showed up yeah they
showed up to lock me up in a psychiatric
ward yeah and they they had reached
knoxville tremaine knoxville jeff
tremaine the director um tripp taylor
the executive producer of jackass um
uh who ought to say cordell cordell
mansfield the sound guy uh red costume
big red was there but he was just he was
just weight he was he was just uh but he
was there to take care of ted you're on
it you're in the information loop but
you're not you you weren't able to well
nothing he was he was they asked him
explicitly to be there and dad that uh
in a controversial move said no i
refused to be at my son's intervention
tremaine called
uh knoxville
sent a couple of emails and called
uh dr drew
uh was very concerned so if you don't
get steve off the street within 24 hours
he's probably going to die
and
then knoxville
really kind of
played the responsibility card if you
want to call it that and said
[ __ ] if my son was in that situation i'd
be out on a heartbeat i don't understand
what's holding you back
and uh that was maybe the toughest
decision i've ever made
but your thinking was what my thinking
was as steve described how
despite the strength of our relationship
i could never talk to him about
lifestyle he would just shut down
and so my rational rationale was
these guys are his friends
his workmates
he looks up to them they have influence
with them they talk that same street
cred language if you want to call it
that
if i'm in the room
if i'm if i'm in that room
all these guys are going to shrink back
against the wall and it's going to be a
pissing match between steve and me and
the center of the room and i'm going to
lose yeah it's going to work across if i
don't go
then these guys are going to have to
take responsibility and steve will
listen to them more than uh he'd listen
to me that's pretty insightful actually
they will get the job done and four days
later when he was in the uh
psychological
side
i flew out and spent a week there gotcha
wow
and and then uh and and and um
i was in the psych ward for seven days
they extended my stay uh by changing my
status from 51.50 which is three days to
52.50 which is two weeks and after seven
days i determined that uh that i really
did need help and that i was willing to
go uh seek help and go into a treatment
center um
so dad what is that but let's let's park
it there for a second i mean first of
all i would imagine you're doing the
thorazine shuffle for like a couple days
in there right like trying to detox
um well when i first got showed up um
they had uh
they got me into into a car you know i
mean the idea of the intervention wasn't
it
you know they can like the kind of tv
they say are you willing to accept help
you know it wasn't that variation or the
you know it was um it was you know they
were there to inform me that i was gonna
get help and i was going to a psych
court and then if i didn't like that
that they're
quite plainly going to beat me up and
take me against my will and so i didn't
feel like getting beaten up and i went
willingly
so we got into uh into a car with an suv
and i was in you know knoxville and
tremaine were driving me to the hospital
when we got to the hospital there was a
guy waiting at the curb with a uh a
wheelchair you know thinking he's gonna
wheel me in and i got out of the car and
uh you know i looked at the guys i don't
need no you know [ __ ] wheelchair
whatever and i just and i spit on the
guy you know that was kind of like uh
not unusual for me to spit on people at
that time in my life and um
so i walked into the hospital and i was
just sure that i was gonna explain it
was you know calmly explained it was a
misunderstanding i was just i was very
lucid i was you know i was kind of i had
an ability to kind of turn on like you
know like uh lucid and
sensible seemingly of course man every
addict alcoholic knows how to do that
when you know when the time comes and
you gotta like show up and like convince
people that you're okay right and and uh
and i probably would have been able to
do that if it weren't for those emails
that i provided which they had printed
out to document why i was uh why i
qualified for california's 5150 law but
um when when i determined that i
couldn't um
when i wasn't able to uh
talk my way out of it and that i wasn't
you know
going to be locked up i became
belligerent and threw a temper tantrum
and grabbed a chair and went to throw it
and as i tried to throw this chair
i got tackled by like hospital orderlies
who slammed me down onto a uh
like a stretcher and and and then they
jammed the needle in my butt cheek which
i understand to be thorazine yeah and
then you're out like yeah yeah they put
a needle in my butt cheek and i took a
nap that was as simple as that and um
now when i woke up um you know then
there i am now i'm introduced to the to
the psych ward you know where the doors
don't open
um i i was like really clear about um
about uh
i know what they want to hear
you know i know what they want me to say
they want me to say i'm gonna i'm gonna
like you know stop doing drugs and you
know get sober like uh i was kind of
negotiating
with like uh in my head
for the first few days in there thinking
yeah it probably really is a pretty good
idea for me to quit doing ketamine you
know like like uh this special k is
really just not good for me and i don't
uh do myself any favors when i'm on it
and you know like
i don't know if i can but i probably
should think about stopping doing coke
you know but but then like that but then
like
just no i can't but but when i got done
like i i i gotta be able to maybe
drinking i could think about it well i
don't know i mean i'm gonna quit
drinking you know but when i got to weed
i was like no i will not you know
so it's kind of like i was figuring out
in my own mind but maybe i'll tell them
what they want to hear but what i'll
really do is this and that
and just over the course of those seven
days that i was in there
um you know a number of things happened
with people coming in to talk about
sobriety and and somebody gave me a book
about sobriety and
um
ultimately it was like wow okay you know
like once uh i'd heard the people tell
their stories and and and kind of read
in this book
and and then taking the 20 questions of
alcoholics anonymous which they gave me
yeah well i'm sure your perfect score on
that oh dude i aced it yeah of course
totally aced it except for like that i
could probably i think that in hindsight
i could i could have argued
that some questions were were not
applicable to me
but it's not like the the clouds parted
and you know the angels were singing and
you were blessed with this like moment
of willingness and it wasn't like that
but it also kind of was something
clicked and this there was a distinct
something clicked because i uh i i
you know i gave up on on the whole i'm
gonna continue to smoke weed thing when
i made the decision you know when i made
the decision seven days into the
psychiatric ward said i'm gonna go to
rehab and i'm gonna learn how to live
clean and sober i'm in a hundred percent
clean and sober right i gave up any idea
that i was gonna continue to smoke weed
that i was gonna continue to drink and
that that that that arriving at that
decision what do you think that's a
function of like what was going on that
got you to that point it means like
you've been in rehab before
you know when you went in you weren't
exactly it's not like right you didn't
know you were an alcoholic it was 13
years prior my one experience in rehab
and uh you know what what it was what
helped me to get to that was i would say
primarily humiliation you know like i
i i my reality was that i could not get
through any given day without performing
some
uh dreadful
thing
that just brought about like frankly
humiliation you know um or or just guilt
and shame and remorse like when uh you
know i would like in the moment of uh of
my bender you know on my whatever drug i
was on and sitting at the computer
firing off emails like in the moment of
sending every email i thought it was
just pure genius i thought i was like
just oh this is great i'm amazing like
oh this is this isn't wrong this is
justified you know whatever and then and
then it's like to to wake up the next
day and and realize what i had done
um god it was just humiliating you know
and um and there was so much of that
going on and it was like a daily on a
daily basis i was just humiliating
myself well the more humiliated you are
the more you got to use right it's a
cycle absolutely for sure it's a cycle
and like and it was just uh that's what
i think like really
from that and just how sick i was you
know like um
i i just the seven days in the psych
ward and and the experience that i had
in there with the various people that
came in to talk to me um
like and the humiliation and in all of
the shame and remorse
it was sort of a perfect storm of uh you
know it came with the clarity that i
needed help right i mean the the
trajectory the arc has been pretty
amazing i mean it would have been one
thing for you to okay stevo's sober and
then just live your life but i've seen
you know just from my outside
perspective looking in on your life and
i don't know that intimately but you
know you really grabbed onto this thing
i mean you did the rehab super hard
where did you go to impact or some place
like that no it wasn't that i went i
bounced around i went to the goodin
center in pasadena it's not like uh i
started out at it
is that true
was true he's long since washed his hand
to that place but um but yeah and i
showed up like when i when i got there i
was so serious about it and uh dr drew
was the chemical dependency or the
director of the chemical dependency
unit of the hospital and i remember and
i was with dad
um i said to uh to dr drew i said
however long
you recommend that i stay in here in
this rehab
i want to go ahead and stay
significantly longer
because i i was clear on on uh having
heard all the statistics about like 95
percent of alcoholics dying drunk of
causes related to alcoholism and you
know the staggering statistics of of how
uh it's not
um you know the odds are stacked against
us you know like they they'll say like
look around you in the rehab 12 of you
and only one of you is going to make it
or this and that i knew the dodge went
on in my face so how long did you stay
in that rehab he said that what dr drew
said
was i recommend i don't recommend you
stay more than 30 days here in in los
angeles which is thank god because i
think that 30 days was pushed 100 grand
or something like
whatever whatever it was it was it was
obscene
and um
and uh and he said but if but if you
really are the serious about your
sobriety then what i'm gonna recommend
is that you go from 30 days in here and
you move into a into a sober living like
a halfway house and uh and that was
there for two years right i stayed in
sober living it's like for two years is
a long time where where was that so
we're living home yeah i bounced around
what happened was uh you know i was in
rehab for the 30 days and and i wasn't
committed to what the next move was you
know
but i was i was just very willing to do
whatever i could to
give myself better odds you know to give
myself an advantage and um
you know invariably on any given day in
uh in the rehab at los angeles there one
of the other uh patients was always
just uh
you know antsy like i gotta get out of
here i gotta get out of here i gotta get
my kids i gotta get back to my kids i
gotta get back to my job i gotta go do
this i gotta do that and the counselors
would look at them and just sort of uh
you know very matter-of-factly say hey i
get it you know but what you're talking
about is getting loaded you know they
said if you make any uh if you make
anything your priority
other than uh your sobriety then then uh
you're gonna lose it and you're gonna
lose your sobriety unless you make your
sobriety your only priority and um
and and faith for me at that time was
like pretty simple it was just like i
had my faith in those counselors having
done devoted their lives to to a
constant stream of new people coming in
and and uh and and going out you know
and just the turnover every day you know
like it's the stream of of addicts
coming through that they would have
figured out you know after years of that
what does and doesn't work and when they
so plainly a matter of factly say you're
going to get loaded if you do that i
believed them and so i just sort of you
know did what they said uh you know i
got the sponsor i did all those things
that that are uh that are recommended
um and uh and and in the process of
working with the sponsor and looking at
you know
like all the stuff we look at the
inventory and all that like i just you
know i had i got the fourth step blues
and wound up you know and and psych ward
number two never got loaded but uh but i
had a question
yeah that's self-loathing that it talks
about
in that fourth chapter
you can't linger on the four on four too
long you know you gotta get through
get rid of that stuff i'm more i
morbidly morbidly put myself on trial
with that uh with that
so you like clinically diagnosed
depressed they i mean they diagnosed me
as bipolar they you know they prescribed
me like
they'd make fun of me in rehab they'd
call me medicine boy
the way you told us at the time
you realize that your computer
was
becoming part of the problem because it
communicate let you communicate to the
outside world and you're trying to
prove to everybody you know the right
way to go through all this i was
different
and so you you gave it up
uh voluntarily and i always understood
that it was driven by your obsession
with the computer that ramifications
beyond that but when your sponsor took
away the computer for a week well i
asked him to take away my computer and
not for a week for for months on end but
you know one thing about steve i've said
before
the world is full of stupid people that
try to make like they're intelligent and
they fall on their ass
uh steve is a very very smart guy that's
making a good living out of pretending
that he's stupid
[Music]
[Laughter]
and what it is in a nutshell and and
and one of the things we had this
discussion just the other night
steve has
a very sharply
defined comfort zone
most people kind of go from white and
between white and black there's
progressively more gray as they become
less motivated and less proficient but
they're still functioning
steve within his comfort zone within
that white area is second to none i mean
he's committed he works his ass off he's
very smart
he gets 11 out of 10.
but step three inches over that comfort
line and he's as useless as touching the
ball
he just
i mean when did you when did you come
into that awareness i mean you're a
traditional guy like you know
when steve's a little kid when do you
start thinking what am i going to do
with this guy like where you know where
am i going to put like you know you're
sending them to good schools and you're
thinking you're probably thinking i'm
gonna you know raise him to you know be
my shadow or i don't know what you were
thinking but at some point you had to
realize like i got a square peg i'm
trying to jam into a round hole here
well there's a moment uh and i guess you
were it was pre-jackass but not by much
i grew up in a family that was
principally academics my dad was a phd
in history my mother was an m.a in
english
my brother's a phd my sister's in mma
i've got a
niece who's a director at the courthold
art industry in our art
facility in central london with a phd in
art history and i'm the only one of the
family that went in the business and i
wasn't ashamed of it but
i kind of thought myself
a little bit
as a black sheep
growing up in this family of academics
and at a point in time i guess i was
either
about to finish or just finished my
undergraduate at college i never went
beyond that i just got the bachelor
degree
my dad pulled me aside and said you know
i really don't care what you do i mean
don't have any hang-ups do whatever you
want to do just make sure
you do it as well as you possibly can
and you do something that you're
enjoying while you're doing it as well
as you possibly can
and that kind of resonated it took a
while for me to bring steve into that
tent but we had a moment of reckoning
where we had that conversation it was
october of 1998 and dad
pulled me aside and he said son i have
to i have to acknowledge i have done a
disservice to you by not supporting you
in this career path that you've clearly
committed yourself to
what career path is that though it's
like how do you take a kid i'm like i'm
interested in what steve was like at 12
15 and you're trying to parent this guy
who's like you know a wild stallion that
you're probably trying to break him in
right like how does that work well i'm
not sure but i'll give you you know sort
of an example
he said this before and it's been it's
in his book but i guess he was
uh 12 or 13. uh we were living in
toronto
and the motley crew were coming to town
at the time the motley cruise at the
time at the time i was head of the uh
uh nabisco canada
uh operations
and we had
skybox we had we had several sky boxes
in the uh maple leaf gardens which was
the arena at the time
and
there was certainly nobody in the
executive ranks of
nabisco canada that were going to go to
the motley crew
so i thought i was going to be a pretty
good dad
and i came home and i said steve guess
what
i've got us the skype because that was a
motley crew fanatic i love them so much
i said i got us the skybox for the
motley crew and even better
i set it up so that our company
chauffeur is going to bring your
recording equipment into the box so that
you can record the show while we're
there and i thought son of a [ __ ] i
really got a 11 out of 10. out of the
year steve looked at me and he said dad
that's lame
watching molly cruz through a plate
glass window sucks so then so then i i
had to improvise and i said i'll tell
you what
you know you get better tickets
and
i'll go with you to the gardens and
we'll sit in your seats and he took the
challenge and this was unbelievable one
sunday one sunday afternoon let me
finish one sunday afternoon
he spent four hours
going through the then paper yellow
pages of the toronto phone book calling
every hotel in the city asking by name
for the manager of the motley crew and
after about three and a half hours
he caught up not with a manager but with
a manager's brother who was so impressed
with steve's initiative he said i'll
tell you what you got six row
front seats and backstage passes so he
met the challenge he got better tickets
than i did and we went with his tickets
and he went and met the crew afterwards
and then the thing was really
astonishing i was just blown away by
that
and
from then on
um
almost a real curse because when every
shitty report card came in dad said son
if you could just apply the the
motivation of tenacity the the the
initiative they gave they gave they
applied to meeting motley crew he said
if you'd get straight a's your life
would be great yeah and you know what
but what he said and it took a while for
me to say it like years not weeks or
months and it really resonated with me
he said you know i really every time you
said that i really took it as a put down
because the way i interpreted steve
talking is that you're saying dad that i
peaked out at age 14 and everything that
after that is going to be a failure
and that really got me thinking right so
you're clearly industrious when you get
your mind set on something like you can
channel that energy but it's like what
are you gonna
like there is no career path for what i
mean you could have never seen there's
like
what is it where do i i'll tell you
where it went and and and this
progresses the story uh
he decided you want to be a stuntman
and this was a job title this is so
great because this was uh like when i
was dropping out of the university of
miami it was 1993. i was just still on
this i'm going to be a stuntman i'm
going to be a stuntman so 1994 1995 i'm
like
accumulating home video footage of like
like genuinely pretty reckless crazy
stunts for which i would uh ultimately
you know like get some traction dad was
busy going to the
library
there's a uh
i'm not sure there's a library or an
archive of cinematography just off
russell square in central london in the
age of soho
i thought you know i've heard and read
that stuntmen are going to be made
obsolete by digital technology
i'm going to go there and we my wife and
i spent
probably three hours in this place you
know going through all the records about
digital technology and the evolution of
piling an argument to shut me down and
and uh in those days obviously there's
no internet
and
you know if we paid the equivalent of 25
cents a page or something we got paper
copies
and so i would got copies of the uh
all these articles
and uh stuck them in the mail the snail
mail to get them to steve and eventually
they got there and about a week later i
said you know have they arrived have
they arrived yes they've arrived and i
said wow that's terrific isn't it now
you can give up this
the logic right you're stuff logical
argument and so his answer is even more
logical he says fine if there aren't
going to be any stunt man's in the movie
so be it i'm going to get a bunch of
crazy guys like me and we're going to
put together a stunt circus and tour the
country
and that's what jackass was on that's
basically what happened
yeah i mean how do you first meet uh you
know the crew like how do you meet
knoxville and yeah
there was a skateboarding magazine that
brought us all together
um
it was uh a skateboard magazine that was
kind of thinly veiled it was mostly just
sort of uh for the purpose of being kind
of naughty and and crazy and offensive
um
and they made these videos
and uh you know i was a fan of the
magazine i'd be i kind of worked my way
into their good graces and you know did
stunts and crazy stuff in their
magazines and videos
and ultimately the guy in charge
uh reached out to spike jones he was
friends
from the skate from right
he said hey uh spike you know um
our big brother that's what it was
called big brother magazine and the big
brother videos he said we're so popular
they've really like you know gone crazy
with popularity but i get the sense that
they're not at all popular because of
the skateboarding and he says nobody
really cares about the skateboarding
it's all this other nonsense going on in
the videos
that uh that's really uh catching fire
and um he said i think that if we were
to subtract the skateboarding from the
videos and what's left over it could be
a great tv show
and i don't think anybody else could
have really done that um
uh with any kind of kind of hope for
success um
because it was just such
such lunacy it was just such like really
crazy nonsense i think anybody else
would have uh you know come to mtv or
wherever they went and and they just
would have said we can't right put this
[ __ ] [ __ ] on tv we can't we can't put
this on tv but the thing was it was
spike jones like presenting the thing so
it's like wow oscar
hollywood movie director spike jones has
this crazy thing like a kid now i could
work and i think that spike really
you know i don't want to uh give him all
the credit but i think that he really um
by believing in you and and putting his
like stamp over right now
i think that he got uh
he got corporate america to take
seriously what they you know arguably
shouldn't have
yeah but you you're oversimplifying
you're taking a very linear look
at how you hooked up
with uh tremaine
and the reality was
in those days you were going shotgun you
were sending v6 vcrs in fact you have
kidding steve there were months when his
federal express bill was larger than his
income
and
he was shotgunning these things out and
that motley crew energy the ticket
is the same thing yeah i had the the two
vcrs connected like in my sister's
living room taping the tapes just taped
tape tape to tape it was like a [ __ ]
assembly line and i had like and then i
wrote on the little sticker on the the
that came in the blank
the cassette tape
and the sticker for the spine of the vhs
tape and then i would write stevo stunts
and party tricks
like who wouldn't want to watch stunts
and party tricks
and and then i would like like what kind
of people are you mailing this off to
like largely people in the skateboarding
industry but generally like anybody who
uh i thought might watch it like even
like like uh in town agents that i would
dig up online like um i would i'd send
i'd send that [ __ ] everywhere and so is
that how you connected with knoxville or
how did that come together um the uh
i don't think i i had sent tapes to to
big brother i was just a fan of big
brother and when big brother came
through uh my town which at the time was
albuquerque new mexico
um i just made it my mission to track
them down and and uh inform them that
they were gonna
publish an article about me because i
was just so gnarly again the motley crue
story one of his comments
i got my damn article
but the the interesting thing we've
debated since then
is was it easier when steve broke in or
more difficult than today
because he was
recording all this stuff on his home
video camera and going real to real to
make the vcrs and sending vcrs by
there was no uh
you know internet as we know it today no
uploading downloading capabilities
so he had to really work his ass off you
know to get this stuff out
but he was doing it without very much
competition
you know very few people would have his
energy and commitment to make that
happen yeah now everybody has
distribution in today's world anybody
can distribute anything instantly and so
the uh you know it is easier
to uh gain access but it's got to be so
much more competitive there's more
people doing it with more people doing
it and i think the argument can be made
that steve got a big boost by the low
technology as compared with today's
higher technology yeah that's
interesting i think i did better when
doing it at the time when i did because
i was sort of uh like
my medium
uh was
such like i would
i i wouldn't really film a lot of heads
and tails it was just i wanted a shot of
me flying off the roof of the building
you know the difference is that nat if
you were doing it now you just have a
youtube channel and you'd be blowing up
your youtube channel and that's all
you'd need it would you you're like i'm
going to get a million subscribers and
then you know
but but the point is anybody can do that
now right when he did it it required a
lot of initiative a lot of effort uh a
lot of
you know stress if you will i mean you
know putting out
the small amounts of the urine whatever
odd jobs he had buying all these
whatever drugs he sold
that's an odd job
actually that's a that's a career
but
i mean as long as steve is within his
his is clearly defined circle there is
absolutely no stopping
but that's what that dad put in another
way one time which i thought was even
more eloquent uh he said um
when
when steve sets his mind to it uh he can
accomplish
just about anything the problem is
that's a fair fairly narrow slice of the
pie
of what i set my mind too well i would
have i would have presumed that you
would have been
a dad who would be thinking like my
son's out of control i just hope one day
he's gonna wake up and grow up and then
you know kind of come and join the fold
like and get a real job and like be an
adult but what i'm hearing and what i'm
getting is that you really were
supportive of him trying to figure out
what he wanted to do and pursue his
dream well adam
to a degree yeah like i i was flailing
around i wasn't you know
getting any traction whatsoever in my
pursuit of a career as a stunt man but
at a certain point you know when i moved
to albuquerque and i moved in with my
sister there and i had on my sister's
floor the vcrs and i was this and that
um and i was i was uh
you know back in school
um my sister found out about ringling
brothers and barnum and billy clown
college and and she came home with that
information you know that it was free to
get into if you could get in
super exclusive uh but if you could get
into it it's free
and she i think probably thought like
you know this would be great for my
brother like i also could get him the
[ __ ] out of my house
um but uh but yeah when i heard about
that i thought well you know um
if uh if i if i had that circus the
affiliation with ringling brothers and
barnum and billy circus and i was a
trained professional you know and this
then people would take me more seriously
with all my idiotic you know sort of
light myself on fire at the keg party
you know stunts and um
and so i made it my mission to get into
clown college and i did i you know i
pulled that off and um
when i went to clown college it was like
a big deal and that was where like [ __ ]
started
kind of
i guess like my my antics were really
showing some signs of professionalism
like leading up to that point and
particularly from that point on
and um
my mom
i came to my uh my clown college
graduation the gala ceremony you know
like it was a really major big deal and
dad was conspicuously absent this was uh
in september of 1997
when uh when that happened
and um
again the talk that dad and i had was in
october of 1998 so dad hadn't fully come
around yet and dad was like
like pretty like uh dead set against
like you know the idea of supporting
clown college
dad couldn't wrap his head around that
and and uh and and but
like no that's not true okay the the
remember uh
you know
i mean perhaps dad was in england at the
time no well maybe i can't remember
remember mom and i you know were
divorced that hadn't been totally
amicable and i remember thinking at the
time that this could kind of be her deal
and that it might not be
quite as important as my mom showed up
drunker than [ __ ]
but but it was more in my mind it was
more uh you know kind of
a voluntary sharing
all right because
before we had our conversation about the
uh
uh support you know all the rest of it i
was certainly in your camp when you were
interviewing for the job on
the uh
cruise lines well right but that um
that i wasn't on the cruise lines until
1999. yeah but that but
it was wasn't that before it was
after our conversation was 1998.
and when when i remember specifically
because mom had mom was you know the
chronic alcoholic and she had she
suffered an aneurysm which brought like
uh you know us sort of family members
from uh wherever we were my sister and i
in albuquerque dad flew over from
england and we all sort of convened like
uh you know and over this crisis with my
mom and she survived the aneurysm but in
you know with terrible
uh you know
terrible uh
handicap handicap yeah but physical and
mental and and she was just in terrible
shape for the last five years but it was
it was amidst this crisis and it was
actually at the hospital where they had
mom
um in the icu
and um and dad you know you're right
yeah i remember that now it was it was
it was it was outside it was actually
not outside the hospital we took a you
know we were in the hospital with for
mom and we went to like some like pub
slash restaurant like a kind of english
pub type place and it was it was a
i want to say like even like we went
outside like i think i went outside to
smoke a cigarette or something and dad
followed me out and sort of sprung on me
this uh really thoughtful conversation
which is why i know it was october of
1998. and when i
remember chasing around coral gables uh
trying to buy you the uh long
material like for your your st you're
still of the the oh yeah yeah that was
way later that was the way okay way
later that was once i had the the plan
to do the film for the pilot for mtv oh
okay um but uh the thing was so great is
that when dad um pledged his support for
me and in this thing
right it's so funny to call it a path
because there was no pass
how did you even there's no like where
are you gonna take this there was no
there was no path but but dad was you
know okay so you're going to do this
you're committed and i support you and i
remember um like just very shortly after
that you know like um
seeing a uh
a commercial on tv for for the show that
they had at the time which was called
real tv now at that time
there was enough uh there were enough
home video cameras to sustain america's
funniest home videos
like uh and you know and but now like
the video camera was becoming kind of a
more commonplace household
you know reality tv was slowly because
the real world had been going on for a
while but there was other perhaps yeah
but but what this commercial said was do
you have any home video that that you
think that we need that we uh should see
or that we might if you have any home
video that you think we might want to
see
send it in to real tv and they just you
know it was just this hodgepodge of like
crazy like caught on camera home videos
stuff and and and and you know like i
was just feeling kind of gung-ho and i
think dad like
put some wind in my sails in that regard
and i called up their number and i said
i don't have video that you might want
to see i have footage that you need
desperately you bad you need badly
you're hurting for what i have you know
and uh and i sent in um i sent in the
video that i had uh you know like about
a compilation of all my stuff and they
came back with oh we want we like the
video of you uh lighting yourself on
fire on the roof of uh
on the roof of this building and doing
the simultaneous fire breathing front
flip off of the roof into the pool below
and i remember thinking is that all they
want is that all out of out of the
wealth of footage that that's all
they're interested in and then there was
some ancillary footage that went with it
like me jumping off the building during
the daytime
um but uh they were offering me
if i recall correctly five and i do i
know it was they offered me five hundred
dollars for exclusive rights to that
video and i remember saying i said to
the guy on the phone because i wasn't
familiar with the term exclusive i said
what's that he said oh well that means
that you don't know that we own it
outright entirely and you don't own it
anymore and i'm like wait a second so
like i don't i don't own it anymore it's
like well yeah you can't do anything
more with it like it's all ours and i
freaked out and i remember like i hung
up the phone with that guy and i called
dad and i said dad ah they want you know
i called this way they won then you know
they're like exclusive they want to take
all my rights and and dad just said son
he said calm down he says calm down take
a deep breath this isn't complicated he
said you said figure out for yourself
figure out where at which point is it a
deal breaker and uh and then draw a line
in the sand and stick to it he said from
what you're telling me it sounds like
exclusivity is a deal breaker
and uh he says if i were you i would say
i'd call them back and say hey you know
exclusive does not work for me you can
have the non-exclusive and uh and you
have to give me a thousand bucks not
500.
and uh and that's what i did and that's
what i got oh
yeah yeah
they they took an exclusive
non-exclusive they paid me a thousand
bucks and um
and that was like
the first thing dad and i like
collaborated on like in a meaningful way
and then from that point like truly and
and and really really like you know this
means a lot to me to say this that um it
means a lot to me to say that that dad
didn't by any means jump on a bandwagon
where he wasn't supportive and then all
of a sudden i had some success and then
he came around afterwards not like very
much the the opposite way around i could
say that i became successful because i
had dad support you know i think that
that was like i mean i probably would
have figured some stuff out on my on my
own anyway but but but but dad really
put wind in my sails and it's great
really put wind in my sails and then
when when the first business
like uh conversations came up like the
real tv one dad was in the conversation
with me and um
and that's just it's it's such a bit
such a big deal um
like like and it it it came to be that
my my career in in uh
in in
i guess capturing and and uh you know i
guess uh
you know selling like the video
which is what it was um it became for us
like uh
an activity like that we bonded over
like very much like like throwing the
football you got this businessman here
he knows a lot about business you need
some advice about that yeah we used to
bond over like when i was a kid like
everything my grades were shitty like i
was in trouble for this i was in trouble
for that and like we just wouldn't talk
about it we wouldn't talk about my
report cards we'd just go outside we'd
throw the [ __ ] football yeah i'd run
the pattern dad would call and he'd
throw it to me and we'd have a great
time and we bonded like that like we
bonded over
yeah yeah you're i think you're missing
a link because
[Laughter]
no it's great how how like your memories
are different you know what i mean like
you're remembering like my dad didn't
show up at the clown college thing and
you probably have some resentment about
that and he's had a totally
i don't think i resent him because i
just get it it just wasn't his thing
like at the before that before the point
where we had that conversation in 1998
where he pledged to support me like i'm
not resentful or
i just understand like i was he just
it just wasn't as
he couldn't wrap his head around
where i got um
you know more actively involved and
committed i forgot real tv but yeah that
was it
i have no legal training but much of my
career was with companies where i spent
a lot of time with company lawyers
and i became very very comfortable
with contract law
and could read a contract and i always
believe that
law is 85 common sense and you don't
need the lawyers involved until you get
past that 80 threshold
and so i would read
the contracts that he got and they were
brutal
i mean his first contract i'm jumping
ahead uh chronologically but the first
contract he got for jackass uh the mtv
contract well mtv's notorious for
horrible but but the point is they were
going to
prevent him
from doing anything
other
than
film jackass shows and i saw that in the
heartbeat and i said steve you're not
going to sign that
and for him they took it out
i forget what the issues were with real
tv the exclusivity thing always kept
coming up
but i could go through and he would uh
and representation deals are even worse
because because then then once you sign
up then they're going to take uh a
percentage of everything that you ever
make and then uh it's gonna renew
automatically and if they just do that
with like a 100 people and then they get
one person that takes off then so in in
in those days obviously he didn't have
the means or the stature
to
have a lot of outside help
and so i fulfilled that role
and by
working through the deals and
making suggestions in the contracts
i became much more involved in the
content of what he was working on
and then we could start kicking around
ideas
and uh i had one idea it still hasn't
been filmed he liked it at the time when
the executive donald the executive
picture this tree-lined
suburban street
in upper middle america
and mr junior executive is walking down
to the
bus
underground
carpool whatever you have it
carrying his attache case
at a point in time he stops
puts the attache case down
pulls out a copy of the wall street
journal
drops his pants
squats down
while he's taking reading the wall
street journal takes a [ __ ]
calmly wipes his ass with toilet paper
out of the attache case puts the wall
street journal back in the bag pulls up
his pants and walks off to do his daily
job
i thought that might be good i think
it'd be good but like i don't know if
stevo is the right guy to do it because
i mean no one's gonna buy the buy him in
the shoot with a national case first of
all at that stage he wasn't well enough
known for that to be an issue right but
secondly the mere fact of steve in a
business suit even before he was
recognized as humor in its own right
because so clearly inconsistencies
you got a production company here you
got like business affairs and you're
like development exactly right
i i remember you i remember it as was
telling me to take a dump into the
suitcase or into the attache case and
then climb so that was that i couldn't
remember maybe maybe that was that
was like damp after talks yeah okay
whether that's my idea or yours it would
make a better storyline no question so
ted where does where does like steve's
like insatiable need for attention come
from
i believe it's because he changed
schools every two two and a half years
and uh in five cases it was changing
countries uh along with the school
and uh
he always was kind of hyperactive and
not highly motivated to school work but
with all this constant moving he was
always a new kid and
he decided that his way to get
recognized and accepted was to be the
cut up
and
that kind of developed the persona i
mean you told the story about how you
banged your nose or something and wanted
to get out of class that's where i
ripped the tooth out
oh that's the story you told on marin
right yeah getting out of class
i mean would you agree with that steve i
think that i mean i believe
like in my in my heart that if i stayed
in one place i'd probably be
you know without all the moving i think
i'd be
an attention [ __ ] as well uh
i think you'd be much less so in fact
you might have been you probably
wouldn't have been successful
because you would have had sufficiently
less motivation that you wouldn't have
put your heart and soul into it the way
you did
perhaps you know and i think a case
study will be my niece i've got a niece
who
if you i think manifests a lot of uh
you know
whatever's going on with me i think is
going on with her except she's lived in
the same place for a whole lifetime yeah
yeah it's like an experiment do you
think that there's
cassie and i are similar
no no she loves reading
she prides herself in getting a's she's
a little bit uncomfortable with the odd
b
i mean i would agree that because of the
uh family genes
there is a
uh
a propensity for addiction
i
agree with what you call the more
monster i think that that's what she
said she's got that look at me look at
me thing going yeah but not as much now
and and uh
there's certainly an overlap but i
wouldn't call it more than an overlap
right has sobriety changed that that
predisposition at all like did you go
through that thing of like i'm getting
sober i don't know if i can do these
stunts anymore or has it change your
relationship with that desire for
attention
uh
i think that
before sobriety i think i just genuinely
didn't uh believe that i was gonna live
for very long you know like uh one way
or another i just thought that i just
wasn't gonna
like uh i was gonna die fairly young so
i was never really driven to try to like
uh
hoard or afford money and and i just
wasn't like particularly motivated by
money i've wanted like to have a legacy
like forever and so the video camera for
me it was like all the video all every
project like man it's like my message in
a bottle and when i'm dead this is gonna
i'm gonna live forever and so i was
really hyper focused on that and it was
such [ __ ]
and
i remember sending you my famous george
harrison uh email you know harrison had
died not too long before that after a
life of drugs and if anybody was ever
going to be leaving a legacy it would be
one of the principles of the beatles
and i said to steve
yeah you can say all this crap but at
the end of the day if they don't care
all that much about george harrison's
legacy you know who's going to really
give a [ __ ] about yours
i think george harrison's got a pretty
dope legacy yeah
i think people do care about you a
little bit sorry
i mean people care about george of
course but he's kind of lost i mean
lennon had more uh charisma
[Music]
my point is
he died at age 58
for all the kind of preventable reasons
that you were talking about on a lesser
scale when you were beating up on me
from my diet
[Laughter]
and i was going easy on them
yeah i think you were too i do the
meeting up well but the uh you know the
point is you live for yourself first and
foremost family and friends uh important
seconds
and uh
who really cares about all the fans out
there who are notoriously fickle and
will jump from one celebrity to another
celebrity and evolve in their tastes
and i remember sending i think i still
have that email and i don't think it
carried all that much weight with you
but i thought it was epic
i'd be interested to see it because i
remember it and i remember the idea of
it and it's like oh dad doesn't get it
like i'm gnarly
but is your relationship to like what
you do shifted as you've as you've
gotten more sober i think that uh
you know as a function like of being an
artist like um
i guess like uh
i don't know i'm just saying like i
think and i kind of say it a lot like i
think that there's there's there's the
the artist and then like there's this
whole new kind of arena of like the like
the person which i never made room for
before you know it was just constant 100
percent
never turn off
you know it was just always on and
always like the persona of stevo and um
now i think that uh you know there's
like a really like there's been like
like you know like a
concerted effort to uh to find
separation between
the persona and and like
the person
and um and it's a struggle man you know
it's a struggle because like i'm still
the attention [ __ ] like i'm still like
like i gotta do this gotta do that like
i still like uh just
you know i i just have aching desire to
matter you know
like to to matter and to be known and to
be revered and and um it's really hard
for me to back off of that
but so but progress is being made you
know is that is that where the
meditation comes in
yeah like i feel like a tm right i do
yeah uh-huh
and uh and i struggle with that you know
i mean i do it i stick with it and you
know like um
like i'm i'm fairly diligent about it
but but
it doesn't come easily to me you know i
don't i don't know
i think alcoholic and meditation is just
a tough mix
i think it's i think it's hard for
everyone yeah i think it's particularly
hard for somebody who's got who's prone
to like you know the obsessive mind sure
you're like hardly somebody you know
eight years ago that somebody would have
said stevo's gonna be doing t you know
tm right they hit it i get it man i get
it and and i'm so glad that i do instead
like even even when meditating is is
terribly difficult and and when i'm like
oh my god
i'm just so glad i'm doing it let me get
back to this thing about the persona i
mean steve glover is a totally different
person from stevo
[Music]
and those boundaries are pretty clear
what i think you're wrestling with
now
is that in between those two boundaries
there's kind of a gray zone and uh steve
glover
never invades the turf of steve oh
but steve oh
can slip across the lines of the steve
glover
and to me that's more a fine-tuning
thing than a fundamental change i think
the fundamental change has taken place i
think it's trying to maintain the
boundaries that is
i don't i don't i see it as such a
such a gnarly uphill battle and and uh
i really do because um
it you know like it's it's the
and and i would compare like with like
you like you've always emphasized how
important it is to have hobbies and uh
and interests yep uh because like you
you
you know you refer to
countless people that you've known in uh
in the the business world who had job
titles who were
very prestigious
in their careers and then from the
moment that they retired or lost their
job whatever the case may be as soon as
they didn't have that prestigious job
title anymore
out out the window went their their
whole identity all of their self-esteem
and like and and without hobbies and
interests they were just depressing like
depressed lumps who just like
had lost everything putting it into a
one-liner sound bites are good there's
two kinds of retirees those who are
enjoying life and those who are waiting
to die
well right sure but but now like that's
what what i relate to
is um
is is is really that what you're talking
about is that the guy who had the
prestigious job title who no longer has
it and now is depressed and uh and his
life is miserable like i re like i think
of that because
like when your
uh identity when your your uh
happiness when when your fulfillment in
life comes from
uh the validation of of uh
you know of external sources be it
people for for the prestige you carry
like that's that's an issue and we call
it in in our terminology we call it
emotional sobriety like like like emote
you can't be emotionally sober
so long as you derive your your
fulfillment your your happiness your
serenity from external validation okay
and and and and by the virtue of being
a uh an entertainer who whose career is
in the entertainment industry it's
really difficult to juggle that because
like because my livelihood is in the
validation of external sources yet like
that's not where the so that the
happiness needs to come from within like
we're very clear on that and for me like
the happiness okay it's like the the
flow of happiness and fulfillment needs
to cease to come from the value of stevo
the commodity and the entertainment
industry and really needs to begin to
come from
from inside stephen glover and without
external validation and that is short
and you would describe it as having
hobbies and interests and and make
yourself happy in the words of jfk let
me tell you this about that
i can't wait to hear this the uh
uh
you've got interests and depth that you
don't even know about
well
help help me and
i
i i i will never forget the time you he
came back
he'd been shooting wild boys uh in
africa he came back from rwanda
and uh
he got to the house about 11 o'clock it
was a late flight coming in we must have
stayed up until 2 30 or three just
talking
and uh he started out telling me about
ronda and got deeply into the atrocities
of the uh
1994 and uh
you know he knew stuff about rwanda
having just been there uh i was i think
it was after i had like after
rwanda and i read that book okay well
but you came back from a trip i think
you maybe read the book on the airplane
because the two seem to be pretty
married together
but
you got into that with the knowledge and
the depth that blew me away and i know
how it came up in the same conversation
talk about leonardo we shifted over to
leonardo da vinci and i knew very very
little about leonardo da vinci and steve
who had read read about the man
blew me away with his knowledge
and uh the thing that
yeah he knew and i i was so
thought-provoking and i'd never crossed
my mind before
is that
a testimony to da vinci's greatness
is that he was openly gay
living in the era of the spanish
inquisition and was tolerated because he
was so talented
i don't know how openly gay was i think
he was known to be gay well what's the
difference i mean in those days what's
the difference i mean the spanish
inquisition was after you i mean
you get into that i can send you a uh an
article about the uh you know isis about
what you know
i don't know if i've kept you up to date
on turkish politics i certainly sent you
stuff about the european union i mean
i can send you just about anything
and you'll read it and discuss it with
interest and you're not a whole lot
different from a corporate guy so
basically the point you're making is
that the interior life of stephen glover
you know exceeds the you know the sort
of public perception of
i'm saying
that piece is a no-brainer but i'm also
saying that i think it exceeds what he
recognizes in himself because
when you're
yeah at the top of the corporate ladder
and you're flying around in
company airplanes
and
you know everybody bows and scrapes
because of your title and you know you
want super bowl tickets you
flick your fingers and your secretary
comes up with them somewhere i mean
that's the lifestyle
that is very very
ego fueling
and you're right when people walk out
the door for the last time a lot of them
have left
themselves behind and they've got
nothing to replace it with
and
yet
you know i've developed interests now
and stuff that
i wasn't aware that i was interested in
when i was working and didn't have very
much time i certainly don't worry about
it about your interest
and you've got that reservoir
that you haven't had the time to fully
recognize
but it's there
and i think that's kind of a middle
ground
um
yeah that you will draw from at the
appropriate time
well it's an interesting uh conundrum
though because you do need that sort of
approval and validation and acceptance
to be able to continue to pursue what
you do and and be you know financially
renumerated for it but it's about it's
about your relationship to that like
it's about your attachment to that like
are you neutral in your reaction and
you're in the way that you receive that
or is there you know what is the ego
component that connects you to that well
i i used to describe
financial success
as a three-tier process
the first tier
is earning enough money that you can
engage in your preferred lifestyle
and for some people that can be very
minimal for some people it can be very
extravagant but whatever it is
and it's shaped by what you have at any
point in time but achieving your desired
lifestyle is step one
step two
is accumulating enough assets
that you secure that lifestyle almost
regardless of what happens so you lose
your job uh you know god forbid that he
have an accident and never be able to do
a stunt again or stand up yeah
enough money in the bank that the
lifestyle isn't going to suffer sure
there'll be adjustments but the monetary
side is taken care of and that's step
two
step number three is what i'd describe
as ego and raw power
and that's when people have far more
than they need and some people give it
to charities and other people
play a real life monopoly game and buy
and sell companies and strip out
people's jobs and do all kinds of things
just for the ego and the prestige i
think that's where it becomes a sickness
and
you know if you can get off the bus
uh at a point when you've achieved what
you want to achieve you've secured what
you want to secure
and you're no longer driven by the ego
it's a feasible scenario that's the uh
that's the rock that you're pushing up
the hill right
and it has evolved because like you're
not i mean with what you're doing now
it's yeah there's stunts and there's you
know stevo being stevo but it's more
performance art you know and comedy like
it has changed and there's another
there's another theme that i've been on
if i'm talking too much shut me up but i
i
love it
uh
i have been beating up on steve for
probably 10 years now
to assume the role as ceo of his own
company
and at the very beginning
one of steve's infamous quotes
was
he was in charge of creative and he let
the other guys take over the numbers and
guess what he got ripped off and taken
to the cleaners
and i said you got to be responsible
you got to learn to manage people you
got to learn to delegate and you got to
be willing to kick ass and enforce
high performance standards
and every time
he complains on the phone or when we're
together and says so-and-so let me down
or
i think i'd get rid of such and such
he's not performing anymore
my stock answer is hey it's not his
fault it's your fault
yeah whoever what i mean some people are
grossly incompetent you find them out in
six months and they're gone but a person
who has been performing at a
satisfactory or better level for a
number of years who suddenly stops
performing
it's because they haven't had their ass
kicked they haven't had their
performance standards clearly defined
and enormous progress is being made in
that front and i believe at some point
steve if he chose to would be capable of
buying into a
viable business and running it as a
businessman yeah well i mean beyond the
the talent and the you know sheer
insanity of what he does clearly a lot
of your insight has rubbed off on him
because you know you've had tremendous
longevity in this business i mean it
could have been like a flash in the pan
thing you know
see you later like oh this guy does
crazy stunts but like you've actually
cultivated a life and and a lot of
staying power in this town which is not
easy and that only happens when
you know you're making smart decisions
and you you do have an entrepreneurial
relationship with what you do
you know there's definitely this uh
you know there's this insane drive that
that i've had and um
you know the the
persistence and the the the
just
drive and i'm sure that comes from dad
and and uh everything else that's rubbed
off on me from dad um
i've been very fortunate you know and uh
and then i've worked hard and you know
and that's key you have worked hard
yeah and you've earned everything you've
got and you can look around and the
field is littered with people that had
uh similar opportunities and failed to
capitalize on them
yeah that probably gets missed you know
by most people or just think like oh
it's just easy for stevo you know just
do crazy stuff and everyone pays
attention it's it's a lot more
complicated than that so yeah so
you're proud very much fun right very
much so and steve you got the you got
the showtime special now you're
traveling like a crazy man it is well
again it's uh
the showtime special is
now if you go on my instagram in the bio
of my instagram there's a link to uh to
what i consider to be the craziest
one-man show that's ever been recorded
yeah this this whole thing came together
so quickly i haven't had a chance to
check it out yet no worries man it's all
good
but i know it's like it's comedy it's
stunts it's craziness it's like you're
interesting
it's uh something i worked on for five
years of touring you know for all the
material
and um
and uh it's just and i i preferred
stunts throughout it that are just
really heavy and and uh
entertaining man like at the end of the
day it's a
it's a cohesive one-man show where i
tell my story and punctuate it with
intense stunts
throughout and and the the end result is
it's a it's the craziest most
entertaining one-man show comedy special
like i think it's ever been recorded
yeah yeah and i say that like kind of
brashly but uh
you know and at the risk of sounding
douchey i just i couldn't be more
thrilled with how it came out and and uh
you know
and i continue to now i'm on to the next
one right so doing you're going to do
another special and you're just touring
well ultimately like i'm touring you
know like it like regardless of how that
special performed on short time even
though it performed very well but now in
this in this you know
in this landscape of media that's so
fragmented and it's so impossible to
really like
reach that many people like you know
whether or not uh that many people
uh see my comedy special
um i you know the fact is that i've been
touring as a stand-up comedian and you
know one man variety performer
um
for
almost six years now
and um and being a part of this comedy
circuit
i've gone back to the same places the
same you know the same venues in the
same cities
time and time again so to the point
where some some comedy clubs i've been
to
five times like every year for each of
the five years like you keep going back
to ohio right yeah i go back to ohio a
lot uh-huh um utah i've been to a lot so
anytime i go back to a place that i've
been to before um if and if i repeat
material that i performed when i was
there the the one time before like as i
do it from the stage i feel
like all i can think about is there's
got that i know there's there are people
in this audience who are saw me here the
last time i was here
and and if there's if they're here and
there and i'm doing the same show i did
the last time i just i'm gonna feel like
such a fraud i'm gonna feel like i'm
dipping them i'm gonna it's like it just
eats me alive from the inside out and
so uh
so yeah i'm just i'm just thrilled to
have taken like that that you know
that what i put on that comedy special
put it out there retire it and be doing
all the materials
[Music]
that's the interesting point because
when you go
on tv
you're not going club by club i mean now
you're out there it's in the archives
people can refer back to it
and it puts far more pressure
to change the material and evolve the
material
and one of the discussions we've been
having is
what next i mean if stand-up is going to
continue
then at some point it needs to evolve
from
you know stevo's life history and a few
crazy stunts
into somewhat more mainstream that
provides a vehicle for changing the
materials right sure and and that's
going to be a challenge
you will meet it you will meet it but i
mean this is kind of an example of a
later stage evolution
like a louis c.k sort of evolution into
sure i mean there's like there's a bunch
of uh of material that qualifies as
stand-ups is not autobiographical in
nature that i chose to uh to leave out
of the comedy special because i felt
that for
for my comedy special it uh
it's a
transitional piece people are like
aren't necessarily ready to swallow
stevo the stand-up comedian right so so
by by having emphasis on stunts being
part of that show and uh
right i gotta lure him in with the
stunts and then kind of convert them
with the comedy and uh in order to make
the comedy more palatable have it be
like totally autobiographical and like
wow we're gonna hear these crazy true
stories about like what went on like you
know during jackass behind the scenes
like what the the kind of impact was on
steve's life and you know this and that
and uh and it's all going to be shocking
and juicy throughout and by the end of
it
um
wow you know this guy's a performer and
he can actually like get on stage and
entertain people with uh spoken lord you
know and he's making my point because
he's thinking strategically and planning
ahead and foreseeing the evolution
and working very very hard to do it and
there are a lot of people that just go
out and figure we give him the same old
[ __ ] and i'll be funnier if i've had a
few drinks under my belt and uh we go on
to the next town tomorrow so you know it
doesn't have to be new i mean there's
two different standards and he
consistently goes after the higher
standard yeah that's great man and uh so
just keep keep doing it like our i know
you got like a like a movie project
you're working on where everything's
projected yeah stuff coming up isn't it
is there ever going to be another
jackass it's not i doubt it man like uh
we gotta get all the guys healthy you
know
like uh
i should say the remaining guys which is
a sad thing to say but uh
yeah if uh you know
the guys that are healthy some of the
guys are uh you know can free up their
time
well it's like a band that's been around
for a long time and everyone just has a
life now right
they missed an opportunity i remember at
the
premiere for jackass too
after far too many scotches
sitting in a hotel room
with jeff tremaine and saying pretty
much the same thing as jeff
you can't keep making this stuff
more and more dangerous it's going to
implode that's what they are saying
about reality tv
but i broke it down in you know into
three components i said there's pain in
danger which is one and that's the piece
that's being outgrown and you have to
evolve away from
there's rank gross filth and that'll
probably always be part of the the
proposition but it may have a more
narrow appeal than you'd like
and then the third piece is genuine
humor
and if you can move it up that scale
and get to a point where
genuine humor takes on
a larger piece
then there's got to be scope for a lot
more of these
i'll take it once my grandpa
accomplished that yeah yeah but that
wasn't jackass it was sort of jackass
but it was basically knoxville's
scripted movie getting away from the uh
uh tradition in his way of getting away
from it right just like you're planning
on your upcoming project but the point
is if there had been an early adoption
of the view that
we can
make people laugh without having to hurt
ourselves or put ourselves at risk it
would have been more feasible
but i think i think you're overlooking
the the most important aspect in the
kind of success equation of jackass
which is the camaraderie amongst all you
guys and the level of endearment you
know like there's a lot of love between
all you guys and that whether it's it's
it doesn't have to be stated overtly but
like that is so like clear and present
when you watch those movies and i think
that's what allows the audience member
to like really tap in and go on that
journey because you guys like you know
you guys care about each other
and
and it's not just like it's not just in
isolation like doing crazy stuff like
you guys were all in it right for the
right for the win together tell them the
story of sad ass
oh well i mean
it's
it's just that every every so often um
there will be uh like one that typically
one of the the this one guy from jackass
will will initiate an email
uh
you know to the whole cast and spike
jones and knoxville tremaine you know um
saying like come on guys come on like
trying to rally to get like a fourth
jackass movie um underway
and um
it generally like uh doesn't catch fire
you know like i really think there's not
really a response
um
i i responded to the last one by saying
hey you know i was in um
tampa promoting shows on the radio and
this this uh radio dj guy named mike
calta said
something that really was impactful to
me he said that when he went to the
theater to watch jackass 3d that he went
with
a fear the nervousness that it would
have reached a point
already that it was it had become sad to
watch us
you know advance in age and continue to
do these things right right right he
said i was just i was worried for you
that it would have become sad to watch
you guys do that he said however that he
was relieved
that um that in fact it would prove
you know to him that we were still
getting away with it it was still funny
the magic was still there and it was
great and yeah but you don't want to
cross over right and and as he told me
that i remember thinking like man you
know he's got a point you know and like
uh whenever anybody asks me about like
are you gonna make a jackass for
i think of that conversation with mike
calton tampa and i think
and i relate i i related this to the to
the guys in the email thread and i said
hey you know um
now like what the point that that guy
was talking about now we're now we're
six years later now
like if we get together and we might try
to make a jackass for it like the
elephant in the room is wow these guys
are [ __ ] old you know like like the
it's the elephant in the room there's no
way around it you know and i said i'm
with all of you like uh you know like um
i i i love all of you guys and you know
i miss you guys and and like all the
enthusiasm is there you know like uh for
us to get together and do something i
just said i feel that it's important
whatever we do do
that we get out in front of that and we
acknowledge okay now it's [ __ ]
getting to a point now it's [ __ ]
ridiculous now we're like now we're old
and would end up
and if there's a way to kind of uh
to modify what we're doing if it's
something like what my dad's talking
about over here if if there's a way to
um just acknowledge it to tweak it i
think that there's a project for us to
to do like under the name of jackass
with all of us involved i just don't
think that we could get away with
sort of you know like the same format
and without acknowledging it without
getting in front of it no you don't have
to i mean maybe you recruit the next
wave you know and train them up yeah who
knows but um but the funniest thing and
i laughed out loud one of the guys
responded with a uh a graphic a mock-up
of uh
a jackass for a movie poster it had like
uh
for the
for the a it was uh
the number four
you know but it said sad ass
that's so good well i think it was for
the third trapper was it the third one
that they came so you got i don't know
if you were there because i wasn't home
this day but i know tremaine and a bunch
of crew guys came to our house to scout
for jackass three for some crazy stunt
what do they want to do like ride a jet
stream
yeah the jet the wave runner thing yeah
yeah yeah and like go because our pool
goes off like this edge
you didn't end up using the house but
like everybody came to check it out and
i was like super long narrow pool
exactly that's your house yeah that's my
house
yeah
i mean you would know if it happened
like it's yeah it's long well you know
you didn't film there but you guys all
came out and scouted and then maybe you
found somewhere else or yeah i wasn't
there but i was like i was like please
let that happen like we gotta have
jackass happening at the house didn't
work out but yeah but it's great because
um you know like i don't think there's
going to be another jackass for i kind
of feel like that that ship has sailed i
personally got sick and tired of waiting
you know for it to happen and so i wrote
this this movie idea
um that i'm pursuing i'm trying to make
it happen and i'm like hopeful that uh
that i'm
going gonna make it happen and um it's a
it's a scripted thing that involves all
kinds of sight gags and crazy stunts and
and uh and a story and um by the virtue
of it having a story
i'm able to easily get out in front of
it and be like hey you know
acknowledging the very first scene like
you know like uh yeah i'm too old to be
doing this yeah do it anyway
that's great man
i hope that happens i do too man and uh
you know and and this is um
this is uh
this is where like what dad describes as
my comfort zone you know which i i've
more affectionately referred to as the
the narrow slice of the pie which i uh
within which i apply myself fully you
know the comfort zone is widening it's
taking long slow painful yeah but i
don't even think it's necessarily
widening i just think this this movie
project falls into the category of [ __ ]
that i will [ __ ] pursue until it
happens right right right right
yeah but you're into the contract you're
into the numbers you're into the uh
uh
you're dealing with it at a much broader
and higher level than you would have 10
years ago yeah sure you got good people
on your team and all that yeah i got to
deal with uh incredibly reputable movie
producers made all kinds of uh he's made
like 175 movies he knows exactly what
he's doing
and uh we've you know we've got a deal
between us we've got the the the deal
with the script guy
and the the script guys like you know i
wrote it but he's making it like uh
official
so we'll see what happens man nice man
well uh congrats on the special thank
you so much
it's great talking to you guys man this
is really no i mean honestly i felt like
i'm just eavesdropping on you know this
conversation between father and son how
about these organizational moments where
like no you've got that wrong yeah
you've never done a podcast you did
amazing and uh i appreciate you being
honest and and open i just still don't
even know what i did
[Laughter]
the last thing i want to say is just you
know i think that uh you're an
inspiration with your sobriety man and
i've seen you uh you know i've seen you
over the years and you really you you
don't just talk the talk man you walk
the walk and you know i've seen the
growth and uh it's cool so
i appreciate that a lot rich and you
know i feel the same way about you
brother it's been it's been great to
see trudging the road together that's
right man
i'm gonna make vegan smoothies dude you
ready awesome do it thanks you guys
peace
[Music]
you